quand vous entendez tout ce qui est dit
là sur les examens sur sur le présentiel
sur les décors contrat qu'est ce que
vous dites moi je voudrais d'abord dire
que je les comprends je les entends que
en temps normal c'est quand même
toujours un stress et une angoisse de
préparer un examen et que cette année
avec enfin c'est ces derniers mois avec
les difficultés qui a eu les difficultés
sanitaires les difficultés
psychologiques etc
moi je comprends que les lycéens les
étudiants ils soient extrêmement anxieux
à la proche de cet examen
la deuxième chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que moi je suis prof j'ai été prof
une très grande partie de ma vie j'ai
été prof d'anglais longtemps j'ai eu des
terminales je suis à préparer le bac
j'ai enseigné en bts fait passer le bts
donc le le sujet de l' angoisse des
examens et de la préparation aux examens
de la notation examen je vois c'est bien
de quoi il s'agit c'est vrai je suis
il ya beaucoup plus et je attendais et
je suis très préoccupé par les
difficultés auxquelles vous êtes
confrontés et j'ai vraiment à coeur à la
fois de vous écouter et de faire en
sorte qu'on puisse trouver des solutions
parce que encore une fois c'est quand
même tout à fait normal que vous soyez
flipper alors bien sûr de l'examen après
les mois et l'année que vous venez
passer de vous n'êtes pas c'est donc
vraiment moi je suis là pour madame la
seule celui où la connaissez l'histoire
c'est une façon de laisser vérité mais
c'est une et l'anonymat dans tout ça le
baiia malmont naissance y être c'est
censé être anonyme aujourd'hui vous
allez vous retrouver avec des élèves
clairement identifiés qui vont être
jugés par des enseignants du public ça
n'a aucun sens
ces discours à chaque fois ils ont tenu
et à chaque fois son tube et derrière
chaque fois vous mettez rien en place
vous parler une fois sortis des plateaux
vent total n'est en rien du tout à en
donner il faut passer à des actes la
seule solution c'est contrôle continu et
de toute manière je vais continuer ma
grève de la faim je vais continuer les
actions parce qu'il faut vraiment
obtenir ce canton continue c'est la
meilleure des solutions qu'attends tu
parles
vous parlez de quoi le contrôle continu
pourquoi pour les épreuves non mais quel
ballet du bac pour ma part le bac
oui mais le bac là il est à 75% contrôle
continu de la part des biens non non
mais attendez non mais juste pour faire
pour bien comprendre le bac là il à 75%
contre on continue donc il ya juste deux
épreuves dans madame pamina congés ils
ont parlé pour le congélo et en charente
et j'ai ce côté pas d'accord je vais
encore le côté pro le brut est pro on a
toutes nos épreuves en présentiel
j'ai encore reçu mes convocations
pendant la grève de la faim aujourd'hui
on est venue mais a apporté ma première
épreuve et le dise
lundi prochain oui comment on va faire
et alors ça s'est passé comment votre
année vous accomplissiez ouais non mais
complètement c'est à dire vous étiez en
distance yale tout le temps vous avez
fait vous êtes en dans quelle branche
vous avez fait quelques belles qualités
je suis chaud en bac pro transport
ouais et non j'ai pas j'ai eu cette
chance d'avoir recours à 100% en
présentiel et à 100 mais à 100% dans ma
classe